all right guys
bang bang man do i have a treat for you
guys today
all right sir thank you so much for
doing this let's do it
welcome thanks for having me for sure um
all right sale so people who do not know
who you are
there's like two people listening who
don't know who you are
uh let's go through your background and
kind of what you did up until
uh pinterest and uh gumroad where were
you born and kind of how do you get to
pinterest
yeah yeah that's 18 years i'll compress
into three minutes or less uh i was born
in new york on long island to two
immigrant parents from india who came to
the u.s for their master's degrees
they were both they both got into
finance my mom was a cpa
my dad became an investment banker i
ended up growing mostly
growing up mostly abroad in singapore uh
which is where my parents are
still at uh went to
usc for computer science and computer
engineering
i had started in in high school making
iphone apps
that was sort of the big aha moment for
me is when i saw that sort of famous
steve jobs presentation in 20
2007 uh you know the internet
communications device or whatever he
called at the time
uh which uh you know made it
made it possible for me to basically
sell directly to to the internet like
just people
you know i didn't even know right i
could just make an app and then apple
would handle like
sort of all the other stuff but it's
sort of i didn't realize was
sort of a fundamental theme in my life
was kind of trying to make that happen
for other people
uh until recently uh got to so i started
making iphone apps
uh went to usc uh ben the ceo of
pinterest emailed me
one day he saw an app that i made got to
the top of hack news
this app called data which i built to
sort of track all the numerical data
points in your life on a daily basis
sort of quantified itself that
sort of sort of movement uh he sent me
an email saying hey you know we work on
this
thing called pinterest it helps you
collect organize
share the things that you love you know
just a few people at the time
you know this is uh fall of 2010 so they
didn't have an iphone app
instagram had just sort of launched
around then and i said sure like i'll
charge you four thousand dollars
uh make pinterest for iphone uh that was
uh
not enough time nor money for me to to
actually finish the project i was uh
didn't really know what i was doing at
the time but i ended up joining
full-time
in january i moved up to the to the bay
uh
was uh employee number two over there
built pictures for iphone
uh among a few other things and yeah
that's kind of how i got to uh
how i got to uh silicon valley
why did you leave school and move to
silicon valley and actually go join
pinterest
yeah i mean i so i really believed when
i went to usc i was going to finish like
i was not that kind of person who's like
i'm just going to go
and join a startup or do my own thing i
was very sold on the degree at that
point
uh what changed things was i mean one i
didn't really know like wow these
startups would really genuinely just
like reach out to a
freshman right uh it turns out in
hindsight
like there was so like so much demand so
little supply
on the ios engineering and design side
that they
they had sort of capped out on people in
the bay they had to kind of find these
these other folks uh and uh
but yeah i mean the way i i sort of
pitched it to my mom and
myself was look i'm gonna i don't know
if this is the path for me right like i
still don't know if like if startups or
whatever this thing ends up being
is where i want to be in 10 years and
it's going to take me
10 years to go like i'm going to go i'm
just going to take four years to
graduate then i'm
going to go work at like google or
something for like three or four years
i'm gonna go to
like a startup you know for like three
or four years i'm gonna start my own
company like that's sort of like the
flow that i saw
uh and and how like how bad would it be
if i
sort of spent ten years and then
realized actually no that's not what i
want to do at all
uh and i don't know if that was me just
like playing games to myself or like i
was trying to like
come up with a reason to sort of i've
noticed myself doing that in a couple
other life
instances as well but yeah i was kind of
like i can find out now i can get paid
for it instead of paying
for it right uh and
uh and yeah i just thought you know like
worst case this is like a gap year
right like i joined this company i get
paid i do it for a year if it works it
works if it doesn't work i can go back
to school
right like i have a sort of a newly
established safety net at this point
uh and you know usc is not going to say
no to that
and so yeah that's kind of how i pitched
a pitch to everybody and uh
and uh yeah it was a i it worked you
know i
have yet to go back i think i'm
technically still on a leave of absence
like usc
you know gives me a phone call asking
for money so that i think they consider
me an alumni but also i don't know
i don't know over there what was it like
when you got to pinterest right so you
get there
uh people see this you know massive
company and great success story today
but you got their employee number two
but what is it like yeah i mean people
ask me this all the time like how was it
like working
you know in the early days of and it's
like well
like i was i was just watching hamilton
and it's like
it's it reminded i don't want to make
this kind of kind of maybe this is not
the most
analogy but like they didn't know what
they were doing right like they didn't
know what would have happened later
right
so i think there is there's this sort of
like when you're in it you're just in it
like you're just spending time like
you're just building stuff it's like
four or five people in a room
right in like a living room of like a
palo alto apartment
with a roommate right and we're just
like building you know we're just
like shipping a website right like we're
just it's like a django app
and you know we have a bunch of users at
the time even right so early but we had
you know tens of thousands of users
engagement was really cool we had some
money in the bank
but it was you know it's like especially
consumer it's like you don't
you don't know what works in that in
that space it's really hard to predict
so it's like okay yeah we'll just you
know keep doing this thing like i was
just shipping
you know features every day i'd come in
you know like 9 10 in the morning like
work you know get lunch work until 6 7
and then leave you know like it was just
not that different than what you do
anywhere else
right it's just like and it's
interesting even gumroad now
like people ask me and i'm like look
it's the same like gummer could be 30
times bigger in volume and scale and my
job would roughly be identical
that's the beauty of software like
that's the point of
automation right is to to make it so
that you can do these things that
are affecting you know way more people
but it's like the factory doing all the
work right you're you're still hitting
the stop start button like you normally
would right it's just like the
throughput
is is a lot higher obviously it's not
identical
but it becomes uh it's it's sort of like
a 20
bump in your sort of like to your
organizational competency to get
to a 10x sort of bump in like you know
the
sort of value creation metric right the
kpi that you're going after
it's really normal you know it's really
normal uh at least
in my in my world and you know bbcs will
come by and like meet the company and i
would like chat with like matt kohler
from benchmark or whatever
but it was very normal right uh i think
that it's actually a problem that i have
because i've never experienced
enough anything except that right like i
was at pinterest and i started gumroad
and that's all and i remember even at
pinterest i was like this thing's gonna
be massive like i think this is gonna be
a multi-billion dollar company and even
like other employees were like
yo like we've been at companies before
and we know this is your first run
but this happens calm this is a common
occurrence where you get super excited
you have all these crazy metrics in the
beginning
and then for whatever reason it doesn't
work and so just like you know like just
hold up hold on to your horses we're
like a 5 million
company at this point right uh and i was
like no this is it this is and it
it was it right but yeah i mean who
knows right was that me like with this
crazy insight or did i just kind of get
lucky and now i got lucky so that's why
you're listening to me talk today right
like
it's hard to it's hard to kind of detach
those things it's not falsifiable
yeah and so what's so interesting to me
about your story is
uh you were there early you did see the
metrics like
you did have that insight of hey this is
gonna be a billion dollar company or
whatever
but then you chose to leave right and
and um
maybe talk a little bit about like when
you first started to think about
potentially leaving like what was the
thought process there and then was there
some event or
idea or something uh that kind of pushed
you over the edge and said i gotta go do
this right now
yeah i mean i really built gumroad as a
weekend project
i had a bunch of these weekend projects
that every few weeks i would sort of
like hack on something just to learn
like python or learn a skill you know i
would basically do that and i'd meet
sort of random people from hacker news
and mountain view and stuff like those
were my weekends and
uh and i built gumroad and that was the
first
project where the next weekend when i
had sort of blocked off the time to work
on a new thing i was more excited about
going back to that
old thing it was the first time out of i
don't know 10 20 different
little little ideas and so there was
something there
right there was something really
interesting about there's something
about that idea
and and sort of like now it might be
more obvious like the app store
basically solved all of these
logistical problems for me so i could
just go make stuff and sell that stuff
i think there was sort of a connection
that i didn't really see there
uh with gumroad and sort of enabling
that same sort of thing for creators
uh content creators mostly but
yeah i just i it was really it wasn't
about leaving pinterest it was it was
like i wanna
i have this opportunity to start a
company
and similar similar to like pinterest
bringing me out of school it was like
such a good
opportunity for me uh that it just was
hard to say no to
and i wouldn't have said yes to like a
subpar company right
just like oh this is only worth it if it
really is like the activation energy has
to sort of like
supersede all of that and i think
government was kind of like that like
investors that started paying me about
it saying hey
like we saw this thing on hacker news
like we see you're an early employee of
pinterest would you ever consider
leaving
and then honestly i'd say the third sort
of element was i think i was just like a
kind of a young stupid kid
right like i joined a pinch a startup
right out of you know i was 18
second employee at this company that was
you know on this crazy
growth trajectory uh you know and so i
was like
i did it once like why can't i do it
again right and i'm going to have like
100x the amount of
options in this other company right so
like i don't even have to get that close
it's going to be worth more
you know and it's actually interesting i
think i think what will probably happen
is they will roughly net out in value it
might like if i just stayed at pinterest
and
but but but like the amount of learning
that i've had
is just fundamentally different right
like there's something about starting a
company and
being the being the first you know
sort of the being responsible for
everything that uh
you know you uh you just learn way more
and like way more people know who i am
than if i was just like you know
sort of an early employee at pictures as
you went through
the decision-making process like what
was the original idea for gumroad
and what kind of um did you actually
when you left what was built and kind of
what was more of a vision
but not yet built yeah i mean it was
really simple the way that i
thought about it initially was it's
bitly plus a credit card form
right so basically all of these people
are building their
audiences on social media directly some
of them don't even have websites
you know they just have a twitter
account youtube account pictures account
reddit account
et cetera et cetera et cetera and so
like all of these e-commerce
platforms like they sort of required a
website right like a paypal button where
would you put it on your website like
this where would you put it on your blog
on you know all these kind of things
uh and so i was like this doesn't make
sense for this new world where everyone
is just getting started building an
audience they might have millions of
followers that want to give them money
and yet don't have a website
right and so that was like the thing was
like okay what do people use to kind of
share content bitly like okay bitly plus
credit card
you know before they get to the sort of
the end content
like let's build that and so that's all
governed was like super super simple
i had all these ideas for like what
could that enable
but i think i think when you democratize
something you just have no idea
right like you you have no idea like
what it what the consumer
sort of behavior is gonna look like what
the traction is gonna be
you're making something way easier way
more accessible
and then you do it and then you see it
okay like
because you don't know how many people
like my vision was like there's all this
content out there
that creators have sitting on their
computers that they don't
currently sell because they're not at
that level that activation energy to
kind of like create a storefront
get a domain do a brand a logo you know
have a bunch of skus
right like really start a business
effectively and they just want a
lemonade stand
right like that's all they want they
wanted to kind of try all this thing out
how much of that is there and i don't
know because these people have done it
privately they don't
sort of share this stuff publicly and so
that was kind of the thing was like i'm
just going to go and that's how i kind
of pitched to investors
uh like naval and max left and i was
like look i don't know where this is
going
but there's something interesting about
sort of just making it what what if it
was you know five minutes to create a
storefront
right what what happens if you do that
uh
and we'll see right this is sort of like
heyday of bitcoin like i think when
government started
actually one of the guys who reached out
to me in those days was this guy brian
who was an engineer at airbnb who was
interested he was like hey
have you ever thought about doing a
bitcoin thing i really wanted to get
into this crypto thing i think bitcoin
was like 70 cents at the time
and i said you know i'm not i it's
interesting but it's early and like i
don't know
what's going to happen so he ended up
starting a company called coinbase
uh which did pretty well uh
but yeah it's just like there's you just
don't know
right like you don't know where the
people keep it's like even the stock
market right like people keep
trying to say oh this is why and it's
just like no you don't know it's a
complex system
and if you knew why you know you
wouldn't be telling anybody
honestly like that you know that you
would you would be uh
you know calling or shorting the market
you know on a daily basis if you really
if you really had this sort of
conviction behind it yeah the one thing
though that i think you did have
um at least it sounds like uh an idea
that was going to continue was this like
uh kind of idea of creators and
audience building and and like you were
basically betting on like a macro
trend there and if that was going to go
away then
this idea specifically probably wouldn't
work but if that accelerated as now with
hindsight bias like
or hindsight clarity like it did this
was going to be something that could be
very valuable
right and so maybe talk a little bit
like why did you think that that
was going to continue rather than yeah
disappear yeah i mean i
i think it's it's finding like the
through lines
just like the to trend lines of society
right and it's like something that's
hard
is going to get easier over time
something that's expensive is going to
get cheaper over time something that
only you know companies with 100 plus
employees can do
is is going to companies with 10
employees or one employee eventually are
going to be able to do
right and so it's all it was it was like
finding those those things and
and and really i really believed like
the insight i think i have i
sort of had to sum it up in a sentence
was everyone was connecting directly to
their audiences right musicians
designers writers filmmakers stand-up
comedians
everyone was it was building a direct
link
to their audience right you imagine 10
15 years ago if you were justin bieber
and you wanted to talk to your audience
you'd have to do like an interview with
like a people
magazine right and now you can just go
on twitter instagram
as much as you want and have a direct
relationship with them and so
but but all of the commerce was still
traditional
right so it's like you'd still sell
through like like radio record store
label publishing house like they're all
these sort of traditional
things and and if you look at the
economics of it right the artists make
very little as a percentage of sort of
the volume that they're really driving
and so i said this is weird like there's
all of this
this sort of like inefficiency in the
commerce side
there's all of this efficiency being
brought into
this sort of communication
discovery side and so my guess is
eventually
this stuff is going to get
disintermediated right like you're not
going to need
a middleman you're not going to need a
label potentially you're not going to
need a publishing house to do certain
things because a lot of these ideas
aren't going to make sense in this new
world right where you where you just
don't need it
anymore right like to me that's always
really interesting like
what if you just yeah like who what do
we not need like what is going away
i think is a really interesting framing
because that's
that's a lot a lot of that is what
innovation is right like what if you
don't
need uh you know a
a dishwasher used to refer to a human
being right it often still does but you
know what i mean like
a computer actually used to be a human
being right like these are people
and jobs that we don't need for our
society to function anymore
and that's great because those people
can go do something else
right that is sort of a better use of
their time
uh more creative use of their time and
so that was kind of the insight was like
there's clearly this shift happening
that i don't see slowing down which is
every single person it's still happening
right every single person is
is gonna connect directly with their
audience
via their blog their newsletter and like
the internet is going to get better and
better and better at finding the right
connections uh you know you're gonna
like it doesn't make sense to me that
like your high school friends are your
friends for life like what are the
chances right that those are the
perfect people for you and your tribe
and your personal growth and development
uh they're probably don't even speak
your language to be honest right and so
it's like
over time my guess is that every single
person
will be able to communicate very
effectively with everybody else that
they want to right and
sell directly is sort of like the next
step of that and so that was
that was the trend but even like gumroad
before gumroad you know that was
happening too right like
people had blogs instead of i guess
submitting op-eds to like their local
newspaper or something right like this
is a
like that's the other thing is i think
there's this why now i think question
people ask
but i really think it's a slope and it's
like it's like it should have already
been happening and it will continue to
happen like the crater economy is this
big
buzzword right now because of covid and
you know all these kind of things
but it but like remote work for example
has like been happening in dreamweaver i
mean i would say excel is like the
premier no code tool
right and that's been around for decades
right uh it's a thing that's already
been happening it's just
continuing to happen and as it continues
to happen
it just makes it way it makes its way to
different people right
like that it's like the william gibson
quote the future is here it's just not
evenly distributed right so it's like
i was already committing communicating
directly with my audience
you know on twitter 12 years ago it's
probably a pretty good bet that
like i'm just early right and there's
going to be way more people doing this
uh and it sort of goes in line with my
philosophy around doing the fun and all
these other things but it's like find
the thing that you
really believe you're early on ios
development right for me was that as
well
cryptocurrency might be that for for you
or other people like
there's it's so hard it's just like
follow your interests like go down the
rabbit hole
and if you if you sort of discover
something and you're like there's
something really interesting here and at
some point in the next it could be
tomorrow it could be 30 years from now
it's going to change the world or
everyone's going to use this it's just
so obvious to you
like figure out a way to like invest in
that thing right
uh you know sort of start making
pickaxes right if you find gold that
kind of thing
yeah and so what's really interesting is
you have this insight uh you build kind
of the side project that then all of a
sudden starts to gain some traction and
people start reaching out and saying hey
do you want to raise money do you want
to leave
you know you obviously are watching the
metrics and at some point you do decide
to leave
now to clear up one of the i think
misconceptions being the second employee
at pinterest does not mean
uh you get to be rich forever if you
leave before your stock fest
which is what you did and so talk me
through kind of the transition now
when did you raise money kind of what
was that conversation like
um and kind of in hindsight view now of
having left before the stock vested like
regret good decision kind of talk me
through all that
yeah i mean probably not a good decision
uh financially at least um yeah i mean i
think i was just you know i
i was not savvy enough i would say as a
what i should have done in hindsight is
i should have been quiet and been like
this thing is gonna work and i should
you know it would be nice to have some
safety net here
so like let me you know even though i
have this cool idea
you know and and pinterest is fine but
not as cool as starting my own company
uh like let me just wait for a while
right but again if i did that like
i would hit my one year and then
every month there's like this you know
so i don't know i don't know if
if that would have been a better
decision for me maybe i could have my
presence would have tanked the company
and pinterest wouldn't be anything today
who knows
uh but yeah i think it was it was just
it was just
i remember talking to josh element about
this he's like look you when i was
telling him about gumroad and
leaving and thing he was like look
you have 100 of a small thing or one
percent of a big thing
right and i just like i'm just like 100
of a small thing kind of person like i
really want control
i want to decide who i work with where i
work how i work
what i work on and just the truth is you
can't do that
if you're working at a different at a
company right like you just can't
right ultimately you're gonna have
you're gonna you're gonna
be put next to somebody and you're just
like i don't really like this person
that much
right uh i just i don't know i don't
think i could ever do that again
honestly
right which is it i just i just think it
wasn't about the financial thing but
certainly it was stupid like i should
have been smarter about it
i should have probably negotiated with
pinterest or something but i just didn't
know
anything right and they didn't either i
think it was like a sort of a new fresh
situation for everyone involved
and sort of a trial by fire but
certainly i think i could have probably
figured out a way to keep you know uh
afford them my stock which i think the
math
ended up being it would have been like
you know 10 to 20 million dollars or
something
for staying an extra you know like six
months or three months or whatever it
was
yeah and look it's also one of these i
love your perspective on just like
who knows what would have happened right
there's a million different things that
could have been
uh but you left and um you said hey look
i'm gonna go take a run at this and
you probably more so than anyone else i
know of
uh have had the ups and downs of kind of
the entrepreneur's journey
um and so let's start with kind of the
initial up which was
you walk out of pinterest with gum road
uh you raise some money
kind of what are investors investing in
who do you go talk to why take kleiner's
money you know kind of
what was that all like as you kind of
started the company
yeah i mean so i i had a few investors
who ping me saying hey
you know if you do a company let me know
you know a bunch of investors who
followed me on twitter so when i said i
was leaving pinterest i got a bunch of
email from that too
and so i just started meeting with
people and this is like the old school
i mean especially with covet like the
way you fundraise today is a little
different but back then
right it was all kind of sand hill road
kind of silicon valley people
and so i would just meet with a batch of
people right like the first set of
people would reach out to me i'd have
like a little like
i don't think i had a deck or anything i
just had like uh the website i would
just go to governor.com on my laptop and
just talk to them about it
and it certainly helps being like
employee number two at pinterest and
and being a technical you know developer
et cetera
um but i would just talk and be like
look i'm building this i'm really
interested in this
sort of democratization of commerce
starting with like the lemonade stand to
the to the shopify like what does that
look like
uh and i ended up yeah and so i would
meet with all these people and then they
basically you know a few of them would
say i'm in like let me know
by the way you should talk to my friend
right and so that's you kind of
there's this tree that kind of builds
pretty quickly that you kind of meet
with you know
a bunch of people 100 200 people or
something you know in a few months that
are
that are interested in investing in you
uh and
i ended up raising a million bucks uh
from
you know naval max selection lowercase
collaborative fund
first round excel sb angel
seth goldstein from turntable and and uh
maybe a couple other folks but uh a good
list pretty pretty solid list
around a million bucks and then and
kleiner happened pretty soon after i
sort of
started i moved up to the city got an
office started building stuff
and i don't really know what happened i
mean i think i think there was you know
like
there's only one series a that a company
can raise
right and i think there's there so there
are like eight to ten firms that are
kind of tracking all these kind of
pre-seed seed funded companies
and i think i must have just been like
one of those companies that you know
was super hot came out of the gates and
at least two firms were like you know if
you want
more money we will like do your series a
and sort of preempt
you know you doing it a year from now
right and so
i sort of just had two meetings one with
index one with the kleiner got two term
sheets
and ended up picking picking picking
kleiner but the the reason was
and i talked to like all my investors
like what should i what should i do here
and josh koppelman from first round he
said he has this great quote he says
there's nothing like numbers to
have up a good story which is to say
you're hot right now like you can kind
of raise on the story that you're
telling
and you're convincing but the minute you
have a year
or so worth of data that maybe shows
there's some holes in your story
which might be true might not be true
you might not be able to raise as easily
you might you know so you're you're
these people are paying up right now and
they might pay up even more but they
also
might see the data and be like oh
there's nothing here right the emperor
has no clothes
and and uh and so i was like yeah i
you know it was a seven on 28 million
dollar
a round so it was like a pretty good
round for a series a at the time
and then i wouldn't have to think about
money for years right like i could just
focus on building the team
on you know talking to customers doing
that whole thing for
two three four years before i really had
to kind of like
think about racing money again and all
these things and so that was the big
reason i did it was like i could just
sort of do it i just raised the seat
around i was like i can just raise all
of this money collectively and then i
can just like go build stuff
for years and really figure this thing
out and not have to context switch
right into this fundraising cycle which
in hindsight i think had some
had some downsides to doing that too uh
but i
but you know it just it was just so the
idea that i could just work on something
uh for years and not have to sort of
you know talk to anybody else and just
focus on building was just so appealing
to me
uh so that's kind of that's kind of what
i ended up doing
and so when you take venture money
obviously they want venture growth they
want
venture exits and kind of slam on the
gas
is is a very kind of crude way to
explain what they
expect you to do with that money um as
we fast forward in your story
uh you end up buying kleiner out for a
dollar at some point
and so uh people who just heard you say
you raised seven million dollars shortly
after raising a million dollars kind of
a husso of silicon valley
and then you're buying kleiner out for a
dollar what happens in between
raising money from them to that moment
yeah i mean we grew
for you know we did okay like i think we
as you mentioned it's like
yeah vcs they kind of think of it like
you you know
like like jet fuel all right like just
make sure your point is in the right
direction
uh before you before you use it uh
and yeah we did okay like we you know we
grew to a nice like probably one and a
half to two million
annual revenue uh business we're growing
maybe like 60 80
a year at that point just not fast
enough
for vcs to say hey this is worth like a
series b
of like 10 15 million dollars right at
like
whatever 100 million or 60 million
evaluation or something like that just
we weren't there
uh and i did the rounds like i met with
all the investors and
uh like all of them because that's what
you have to do when the
when the top ones say no and you kind of
just start going down the list
it was it was good for me though right
because i feel like i had the easy way
the first time the first couple times so
it was nice to kind of not have that
and learn to learn about that obviously
not nice entirely but
but uh yeah we did that kleiner gave us
a a a bridge of 2 million bucks
while when we realized it was going to
be hard to raise more money to really
sort of double down on
on sort of growth uh and not have to do
layoffs then
which would have been kind of like a
death meal for the company and so they
gave us a 2 million
bridge at a 4x liquidation preference so
at that point we had 16.5
million dollars in preferences and
it was like a kind of a hail mary right
like we're gonna try to make this thing
work and hopefully we can like find
something that just like accelerates the
business
but we spend nine months you know
january of 2015 at
october-ish september october-ish trying
to
trying to find that and we didn't uh it
turns out if you didn't find it three
years
into that you're probably not going to
find it in the next year uh something
like coke it kind of has to happen for
that to change
uh which you can't control right uh
but yeah so we did this round of layoffs
we went from 20
employees down to five employees and got
to profitable because that was like
the number one thing i wanted to do is
like look we're paying like two two and
a half million dollars a month to our
creators right like we might not be
like a crazy successful vc business but
like we're still meaningful for these
people
and so like we need to get to profitable
because i can't just turn off the faucet
for them
and so we did that with five people got
to profitable got rid of the san
francisco office in 2016.
and and then i left i ended up moving to
provo utah
i i told my investors like i'm burnt out
like i
worked on this thing for you know four
plus years
it's you know it's a it's a million and
a half in revenue with basically no team
like a skeleton crew
growing 15 20 a year
and with 16 and a half million dollars
in preferences right like there's
like for years and years and years
there's no exit
right like there's nothing if i saw the
company for 16.5 for folks that
don't know what that means basically it
means if i sell the company for 16 and a
half
they get 16 and a half and i get zero
which is the deal that's i'm not
complaining that's just the the what we
have
what we got into but it basically means
like a 16
a a 1.5 million dollar annual current
revenue business
growing at that rate is not worth that
and will not be worth that for a long
time and so i said look
like i tried i'm gonna put this thing on
autopilot
i'm gonna try out the four hour work
week and then
you know write and paint kind of explore
my life and just kind of
take a sabbatical you know have a
quarter life crisis
et cetera so i ended up moving to provo
utah i did that for
you know over two years so i left in
in uh yeah i guess that was late
2015 early 2016 and then uh i think it
was late
2017 uh so two or three or maybe
2018 i can't remember exactly but
kleiner anyways they emailed me saying
hey
you know i had a couple i had some
conversations i was like i'm going to
open source this whole thing because
like
i want the we're never going to build
this great business but like you know
the world can benefit from all this
technology that we've done
and they're like well you know if you do
that kind of as a way to say look
there's nothing here like let's just
clean up the books and like
this is like going to be some free
software for people
uh and they were like you know like
that's still worth something like we
still can't you know
kind of have the ip ownership of that
and like um
but then randomly kind of like three
months or so later they were just like
hey
you know we we're we're you know would
you be willing to sort of
write up you know we'd be willing to
write off the investment effectively
sell you all our shares back for a
dollar
and i still don't know why necessarily
like i don't they have they didn't give
me a reason right they weren't like this
is why we're doing it some
i don't know if it's like some internal
thing or something like tax write-off
thing or whatever
um but i think it was probably just like
you know just like
like sort of married condos so i don't
like cleaning up
sort of anything that that could be
cleaned up you know right before a taxi
or something like that but yeah
basically
they wrote it off and then since then
government has sort of shifted a little
bit
um but but but i think that the sort of
some of the context that gets missed
here
is like a lot of people like haha
kleiner like they lost you know they
basically wrote off this investment that
might now be doing well because gumroad
is in this different place
but the truth is like i think gumroad
would not be in this place without that
having happened
right like they had kind of suffocated
the company
in in a sense because we raised all this
capital and i couldn't work on it just
didn't make sense for me to work on it
and when that went away
and down to two million dollars in
preferences or so
i was like oh like this is now
interesting i started hiring a team
started shipping again
we went from 15 year-over-year to 25
to 40 percent to now over 100 uh
year-over-year
so but that wouldn't have happened right
that wouldn't have happened if kleiner
and
you know i had you know that sort of
like level of preferences that like
would have made
it untenable for me to really work on it
so it's kind of this weird schrodinger's
cat kind of thing right like that
you don't really know um you know what's
what's going to happen
uh and or the heisenberg sort of
unturning principle right like you kind
of mess around with the experiment
um you never know like the sort of the
position and speed or whatever
whatever kind of metaphor yeah so before
we kind of
start analyzing some of this just where
is gumroad today like
what metrics or kind of numbers how do
you talk about where the business is
today and how it's doing
yeah so what i say is we're processing
around 150 million dollars a year
for creators which is you know smaller
than patreon
and teachable and larger than sub stack
and everything else
basically obviously we're a lot older
too um
we're at around 10 million dollars in in
arr we're doubling
year over year largely due to covid
and i think we would have been maybe
sixty or seventy percent without covet
now we're at a hundred percent with
covet um
and we just you know we're just focused
that we have a tiny team it's like 10 15
people
and we just you know we're just gonna
build we're just gonna keep building
stuff
and you know shipping software and
making it better and better and better
and
we're kind of on the the faster horse
kind of thing right like
steve jobs has like the quote i'm like
look like we're happy building the
fabric
the the car could only have been
invented by one person one time right
and uh we're happy with the with the
faster course
creators our creators are very happy
with just you know
focusing on the problem and making it
better and better and better and not
trying to
kind of go too big or try to you know
bite off too much or whatever
yeah and so what it feels like is today
you're running a business that
um you still got some preference right
in the capital stack
uh you still have some of those early
investors that still have exposure to
the equity
but where you kind of ended up is as if
you didn't raise venture capital
right and kind of that's the the
business that you're building today
which is you're using
cash flow to grow and and kind of do
that and so
you've seen both sides right you've seen
kind of the benefits of that and you've
also seen
the benefits and challenges of raising
venture uh you talk all the time about
should people raise money should they
not kind of what's the high level of how
you break down like
when do you raise venture and when does
it maybe not make sense
yeah i mean i think you've raised
venture if there's something you want to
do
that you just don't have sort of the
profit
uh sort of stream to do so right if
you're like i need to solve this problem
and i want to solve it now and i need
some money to go solve that problem and
i'm willing to sell like people always
talk about it like oh you raised this
much
money right that's the term people use
but you're selling a part of your
company right like
that's a big deal you can't you can't
unsell that very easily
and so i i i would say the way to think
about it is like is this worth 10
of your company right like that's more
expensive than a loan that's more
expensive than
the debt that's more expensible
expensive than almost anything right a
piece of your company
and so yeah just you know kind of just
make sure that you yeah like this is the
thing that you want to do and it's worth
selling you know for average sort of
round is around 20
of your company right and so you're
selling you're getting a million bucks
you're also selling 20 of your company
for it and you just have to do the math
is it worth it can you build this
you know without uh without that you
know maybe you should
i think i always you know i i always try
to ride the line between
vc is bad and bc is good because i think
both of those are our simplifications
and i think most people kind of
understand that but
especially people in the industry i
think they do uh there's no one who will
tell you to not raise money faster than
a vc i feel like
but they get this rap i think because
they they kind of like
push the companies in a certain
direction they're sort of this
one-size-fits-all model
but that's you know that's just what it
is right that's just like understanding
like yeah this is what vcs are going to
want from you
because this is their business model and
just like understanding
uh the incentives that they have it's
just you know a good thing to do and not
just the vcs by the way right but early
employees
and executives and everybody you work
with
is trained around a certain incentive
model around their their they get a
bunch of stock
and then that stock appreciates in value
and then at some point they liquidate
that stock which is a very
different model from you work at this
company and you get a profit share
right it's a fundamentally different
different kind of business and
government kind of got lucky because we
basically went down to zero
and so when i rebuilt the company with
new folks and everything i could say
look this is not that kind of company
anymore right so don't join if you're
looking for that because
we have the numbers to have up a good
story now and we don't have that right
uh and it's been freeing right it's
great like i can
like employees aren't sort of obsessed
about are we gonna run our money like
are we gonna need to raise you know like
what should we work on like we should
work on the thing that drives the most
volume tomorrow because that's what's
gonna you know that's that's what
matters and it's now just like let's
just build a great product
right everyone gets paid everyone you
know does the work
and you know it's a very low stress kind
of environment but you lose things too
right like you lose some of the
the impact the urgency the
sort of when you're fighting a war you
know like there's
there's there's some good things that
come out of that too and i have empathy
for that as well
um i just think it's like yeah if you if
like if you have plenty of money
and customers are paying you plenty of
money
you might not have to raise or you might
be able to raise you know like one
password did right like a lot of money
at a very low dilution and sell a lot of
secondaries to do it
and i think it's just it's just about
optionality i think the biggest thing
you lose you do lose when you raise vc
is it is is you're opting for the
liquidity model
you're stating to everybody the way that
we end up making money here
is we sell the business for you know a
10 or 100 x on where we're at today
and that's it that's the way that we're
going to make 99
of the capital you know that come this
sort of return on investment that's when
it kicks in
and so that is either an ipo or an m a
deal right that's about it uh those are
the only two ways you're gonna get
liquidity on your
on your on your stock in like a
meaningful way and so just know that
right just know that that's the
there's nothing wrong gumroad might
still ipo one day right but you know but
but yeah i just think a lot of people
get into it
and they they go through yc they raise a
couple million bucks and then they're
like oh i didn't know that this is what
that meant
i actually have to go for this kind of
home run
strategy right otherwise it's it's not
it's not meaningful
one of the things i've always thought
would be really interesting is
if people talked about fundraising uh in
reverse chronological order
right which is normally they talk about
it as i'm going to raise this money then
i'm going to do x
i'm going to raise this money then i'm
going to do y whatever what you're
really talking about is like why don't
you start from the finish line
and then work your your way backwards
right like if i told you you could have
a business that throws off 20 million
dollars in cash and you and your
employees put in your pocket at the end
of each year like would you be
running that business or would you be
interested in running a business where
basically you have one big payday when
it goes public by the way both are fine
right neither one is right or wrong
it's just that the finish line of
what makes you comfortable or not
comfortable ends up actually dictating
what you do on the fundraising side much
much more than
you know hey uh i need the money today
because if not then i can't hire this
employee
yeah he lost that great tweet he says
like the only thing that
sort of level of what a measure of
intelligence is did you get what you
want out of life or whatever right which
is just to say like look like if you
want
you know to run like a 100 000 a year
business that just turns cash and
you're ha you you want to go live in
thailand and that's all you want to do
and that's
like the sort of the tim ferriss kind of
for a work week kind of thing like
that's great
just make sure that you sort of are
thinking about that and planning
you know that kind of future right and
if you want the
sort of crazy kind of like you know
double or nothing
sort of model and then maybe you get a
bunch of money you know 10 years from
now
but that's the only way you're going to
do it you're never going to be able to
get to that scale or that
level of impact or whatever but you're
also almost definitely
not going to get there anyways like uh
just yeah just know
kind of know and i think the thing that
a lot of people miss like some of the
anti-vc crowd i think when they look at
my journey they're like oh look at this
person he got
you know used her like he was like you
know manipulated her
and i like i do think like one i have
loved every moment of my life
right like i'm i've never been in a
place where i feel like oh i
don't want to be here right now like i
signed up for everything i knew kind of
what i was getting
into and every single time like i
learned i met people
i built my skill set my credibility
so it's like i don't you know i don't
regret it right like i i'm very grateful
for everything that i went through sure
i wish i had maybe had some more nuance
around
around the edges but uh it's
yeah it's way better than i think just
being you know at a company that i
don't enjoy working at which is sort of
an experience that way more people have
right
uh on a daily basis uh especially right
now
that um you wrote this blog post about
uh
not building a billion dollar business
and not kind of being able to
use venture capital to build a venture
scale business
uh the post goes viral and now
yeah you pretty much got a venture scale
business right you're growing 100
year-over-year 10 million dollars in arr
like
it kind of looks like almost what a uh
early stage investor
was expecting or hoping that you would
do his question is did the blog post
contribute to you becoming a venture
scale business but
maybe talk a little bit about the blog
post and kind of you know what
transpired after you wrote that it went
viral yeah so i wrote this blog post
really to sum up
the last nine years of my life like it
was kind of a capstone
for me i wanted to i was just having
conversations with people
and you know people that i thought had
kind of known what had gone down and i
realized
even people like my mom like i had no
context on what had actually transpired
like it just happened i
kind of disappeared you know and
everyone kind of let me be
and and so people thought i'd sold the
business people thought it was dead
like everyone had their own kind of
telephone game kind of going on and so i
was like i'm just going to write this
piece
kind of show to everybody everyone can
kind of know what happened right i can
say that i don't have any picture stock
and like i can just
clarify all of these things
and so i did that and then yeah i just
kind of went went sort of super viral
800 000 people read it
uh i gained a bunch of twitter followers
from that which kind of like
started this like new sort of twitter
thing for me
uh but i think the the the biggest thing
i think that people appreciate it was
like there's just
it was just the nuance of it right it
was like it wasn't like i wasn't trying
to sell anything
i wasn't trying to convince anyone that
you know that like i was on the right
path at the wrong path or like vc was
good or vc was bad
people might have taken that message but
you know it was just like look this is
the story right like i'm just gonna go
through what happened
and you know take it or leave it right
uh and there are a couple lines in there
that i think really resonated with
people but i think the biggest one was
just
that there is like some level of
uncertainty here right and like you just
need to be comfortable
with building not knowing exactly what's
going to happen
right you can't predict like if this is
going to be a billion dollar thing 100
million dollar thing a 10 billion dollar
thing like no one really knows like you
should just really focus on building
something you think is interesting and
valuable for people that sort of gives
you the lifestyle that you want
and and then just be happy where you are
right like just be happy where you are
and then if it happens like these other
things happen like
great you know but it's they're probably
not going to change your life
drastically right if you're if you're
already pretty content with what you
what you have which is kind of
the model that i've been trying to live
my life since which is to try not to do
to set goals and do too much and just
you know even now with gumroad right
like i get vcs that are like hey gumroad
have you thought about raising money for
this thing uh
a lot of that's just bs like they
haven't done their research they don't
really know like the history of the
company
but even you know friends of mine at top
tier firms are like hey
you know but you know have you thought
about this and i'm like look we're
profitable we
make money like my money is not the
bottleneck for us right now
and i know the creator economy is super
hot i know these things are happening
but we still don't know how this thing
is going to play out right and
if you know i'm just not willing to like
it's it's a very different deal for a vc
right a vcc's
a vc gets irr right so like their their
their investment begins today
right so like they actually love the
fact that gumroad
had this nine year journey because like
they're just paying for now
going forward right they're not paying
you know like
if they if they did this deal and then
we had to wait nine years their their
sort of annual return would be destroyed
right
um so now they see it as a great
investment but like for me i'm like i
finally got here
you know like they the when i tell
friends i'm like look i like spent nine
years building this business i finally
have scale
and freedom like i'm going to spend a
couple years just building the stuff
that i want to build for the people i
want to build for with this
you know a little bit more of like a
vessel for me to kind of explore those
kind of things
and then i can say you know let's go big
right let's
let's let's find a new ceo who wants to
go big like i don't know what that looks
like
um it probably doesn't look i've thought
about doing a reggae plus
like doing sort of a crowdfunding kind
of fundraiser around it from our
creators
and the community that might be really
interesting
uh i just think they're i think of
governor like an experiment i think that
the thing that i can do that very few
other people can do is because of my
weird journey to where i am today
i have this kind of weird unique
place where i can basically do whatever
i want i can run all these weird
experiments
within the company i can like try out
these sort of different processes
and software tools and ways of working
in a way that just most companies are
either they either can do that but they
don't have any scale or they have scale
and
therefore they can't do that right and
i'm in this weird numbers in this weird
spot
where i so i feel like it's almost like
my duty to kind of just experiment a
little bit
and like kind of just push the envelope
in ways that are probably bad right
they're probably not going to
lead to change so there's like the lindy
kind of effect there
right but but like i think it's worth it
it's worth like sort of pushing the
overton window a little bit like what if
we don't need meetings what if we don't
need this what if we do need
this other thing what if we open source
all this stuff that no one does
you know and i just think that i can add
a lot more value to the world
on these experimental kind of side
effects of running gum road almost than
like gumroad itself
and i think that's like a really
interesting kind of placed place to be
one of the things that people seem to be
very fascinated about
i think it because it is so different is
you've chosen to operate a business the
metrics that you share
the information that you put out there
it's just so
transparent where does that come from it
comes from i don't know i mean i i think
one misconception is that i think people
think i just started doing it
right after the blog post or like i sort
of like adopted this new style and i was
thinking about
these other folks who've done it like
justin does it really well justin khan
naval biology and i i'm ending i guess
and and and i realized that like they've
been doing it for a long time
like you can go back i mean justin khan
i mean he literally had a camera taped
to his head for
24 hours a day right
so like it's not new it's not like oh
twitter like we
want to do this thing now because we
want a bunch of followers it's like this
is just
what we do like we we like naval has
been writing like i started reading his
blog in like 20
200 set five or seven something like
that you know
uh i just think there's the i think
you're probably similar i might just my
guess
like there's just a personality type
that is like wanting to share all the
time
and it's not really about the sort of
strategic value of doing it or not doing
it it's just like i need to do it
like i need to tell people because
that's how i learned that's how i get
feedback that's how i feel good about
what i'm doing
and i can look like and it's just like a
feedback mechanism like why would i like
i can
do a fund and i'm gonna have to spend
all this time
reading stuff and like talk to all these
people one-on-one
and like make progress or i can just
tweet hey i have a fun no one does that
like i'm it's not even close i'm just
gonna talk about it uh and
and then 100 people 200 people can be
like hey what have you thought about
this what about this you should talk to
like to me like that like it's about
liquidity right it's
when you get rid of some of this
opaqueness it's like why
all the startups have switched like
glass walls in their conference rooms
right just like when you create that
sort of that openness you can sort of
create more of these serendipitous
connections right because you can now
see a lot of it it's just
exposed uh it's like oh i didn't even
know that you were next to me this whole
time and
you know we could work together on this
thing or whatever and so i've always
just been like a
like a core believer in that philosophy
of like and maybe that's because i grew
up
in singapore and there was no tech real
scene there and even when i got to usc
was minimal so i was always trying to
like find my people online
you know on hacker news and twitter and
forums and things like that
uh but i just i do think there's some
sort of like fundamental personality
trait that i don't know what it is like
i don't consider myself an extrovert but
there's this kind of like weird
interesting
version of an introvert or something
that like just
wants to make me like i started painting
i'm like i'm going to create an
instagram account and start posting my
paintings because that's like i want to
have a journal
and i want people to see my improvement
and again give me feedback
and like it's been so great i think all
these people they
wait until they're really good before
they start doing that kind of stuff
right
um there's like and i'm just like why
like
there's nothing to learn from someone
who's really good to be honest
like what are you gonna learn from like
jason calacanis at this point right like
there's just
he's off like you forget what you what
you didn't know
right like you just don't i can't even
when people ask me
about fundraising i'm like look i can
tell you all i know about fundraising
circa 2010 2011 2012. but like i didn't
precedes didn't exist
back then right like there's a new sort
of sort of
like you should actually just talk to
someone who raised money yesterday like
that would be a much better person to
talk to about fundraising i'm happy to
connect with them
and so i think there is this idea that
like i don't know
like there's like strategy behind it but
it's really just like i'm just doing
what i do
and it feels right to me and it you know
just like i got into ios development
because it felt right not because i
thought it was going to change like
everything
and and and it's that sensibility that i
think is what's really important because
i think you have to find that for for
everybody right everybody has to find
that thing that is kind of like driving
them
into an interesting place because i just
i believe there are millions of those
places right and i think you can make
plenty of money
in all of those places and you'll
certainly be happier i think there's
this
worry i have that people kind of see
some someone's success pattern
and then they say oh that's the that's
the way that i need to become successful
but the truth is if you're starting out
today
the way that you become successful is
going to look very different
right because the platforms the growth
the macro trends are different
right like the and i can't tell you what
those are like you have to be a kid
who's like in the middle of nowhere
messing around with like ar stuff or
like
you know audio social networks or
whatever and be like oh this is a really
interesting idea and then spend you know
a few years and it's like all of a
sudden the whole world is like paying
attention
right and i think john carlson says just
you know you have to be willing to go
down the rabbit hole and you just have
to because if truly if you want to be on
the frontier
which is what you kind of need to be at
if you're building something interesting
sort of by definition
right like there's not going to be a lot
of people there like no one's there to
come back and tell you by the way
this is the path right you have to kind
of be the one going into the forest
and like finding the weird thing and you
don't know when you're going to find it
right that's the kind of other thing
it's kind of stochastic
like you don't know like oh on the other
side of this is like the number zero or
gravity
or like it you know or the sort of the
evolution right like it's just like no
you just gotta do it because it's
interesting and weird and
like it just it's fun and it's
satisfying to you
and then you might discover something
like
like the united states of america right
like that wasn't their goal
they weren't trying to do this thing
they were just trying to solve a problem
that they had
and then whoa holy crap it turns out
that this was like a massive
you know massively sort of important
evolution in human history
to get to this sort of like liberal
democracy but
you couldn't have planned for that right
you couldn't have had a business plan
that's like our goal is to create
america and we're this is the way we're
going to do it it was like this very
trial and error thing uh and and that's
sort of just what i think
sort of innovation and invention kind of
need that it's just like this sort of
constant
sort of trying to solve for our problems
and we solve our problems and those lead
to like an
interesting life a new different life
that has other problems that need
solving and then you solve those and
then
you have other problems that need
solving that you sell those and like and
i
i assume that like human history like i
i really believe going back to that
whole early thing
i think that's a fundamental sort of
belief that i have is that we're super
early
right like i think humans if we make it
for an extra thousand two thousand ten
thousand hundred thousand years like i
can't imagine
what that word looks like but i assume
it's gonna be
insane right in a way that i can't
comprehend just like a phone
if you showed a phone or a gun or
something to someone you know
a couple hundred years ago or maybe not
have gone but you know what i mean like
it would be
they would just they wouldn't know what
to do they'd be like this is magic like
we're gonna burn you at the stake right
like
well forget even a couple hundred years
ago i mean literally there's videos of
people who went to jail in the 1980s or
1990s come out and
they look at an iphone like that right
so it's forget hundreds of years
later two three decades right so i'm
still blown away
like i just got a magic keyboard for my
ipad and i'm like
this is insane like this is the trackpad
like it's it's mind-boggling like we're
so and that's why i'm excited to be an
investor but i'm just excited to be
alive because i just think there's just
so much more
i think there's this we always talk
about the black swan right like these
events like covet and these other things
that kind of like tank
sort of like the tail risk right but i
just think we we also we don't spend
enough time
thinking about like what does the upside
look like like what are the what are the
white swans right like what are like the
crazy things that we're gonna discover
and it's like oh that problem that we
thought we'd had to solve
we saw it right like that of x like
penicillin
right or the transistor or plastic
like there are a lot of these things
that like like stripe
has totally changed the game for you
sort of startups getting
you know getting online and and that
didn't exist
you know 15 years ago right and so like
what what is that next thing and what is
that
going to enable us to do and even things
like climate change like i'm
obviously like it's a thing we should we
should work on and it's not going to get
solved unless we work on it but i'm also
incredibly hopeful
that we will solve it like i just
believe that sort of fundamentally
maybe that's not good but like i just
really believe that we just don't know
that sort of what's on the other side
right like what are we going to invent
what are we going to discover what two
things are we going to put together
that very quickly will seem obvious and
and become universal
and it's like can you believe that like
back then we had a problem like
back then people just used to this is
how toilets worked not that long ago and
now
like you know we don't even think about
it or or
food production like there's just so
much
uh there's so much i think there's so
much to be to be discovered even like i
had this moment very recently when i saw
the the what is that like the starship
or something right
like the and i was just like this is
insane
like this thing is like and i i could
like visualize
in a little bit of a future where we're
just going to mars and back or moving it
back like over and over again like an
elevator effectively
and then you realize like that's all it
is like it's incredibly it's rocket
science is actually incredibly simple
which is you just take
like a heavy thing and then you just
like have to move it
like into space with a lot of it it
takes a lot of work
right so it's not easy obviously but
like it's a kind of a simple
physics problem where you just have to
take this thing and like if you could
you would just
you know you just have to move it there
like you're just trying to get this
thing to point it from
point a to point b and then when i saw
it i was like oh yeah that's all it is
it's just like a lot of fire
like you know a lot of explosions
effectively
uh and i could just like and i'm like oh
there's the this is the future
or like the future this has hints of the
future it's like when you see a pain
and you're like you're sort of you're
inspired right you're like there's
something
we're like unlocking something like
we're about to we're
soon we're gonna know why this is
interesting we just know that it is
interesting
we haven't figured it out yet you know
so you've obviously spent the last nine
ten years
uh building gumroad um you've made a
couple of angel investments along the
way
but now we're going to dive kind of
deeper into investing
one maybe talk a little bit just about
some of those angel investments you made
how they went
and then why focus on actually putting
together a fund and going and kind of
being more organized and serious about
the investing activities
yeah so i did just a little bit of angel
investing
previously especially before gumroad i
did five
deals before government when i was at
pinterest and that was really for me to
build
like a mental model of the industry
right i was like okay i'm a founder
i'm an early employee i wasn't really
employed i want to be a founder at some
point
one great way to learn about this model
is to basically take the money i didn't
give usc
and invest into startups so i did i
invested in five companies
uh in 2011. uh two of them did quite
well hello sign ended up selling to
dropbox for 230 million
and one movable inc is gonna do
something pretty well as well and so i
had
just like from five i'd had two good two
good hits and so that was like
okay i have some sensibility some taste
maybe here
uh and then i did my sixth deal was
lambda school i did 2017 there's see
ground that's also
looks like it might be good we'll see
again like
you don't really know right it's it
could be massive it could go to zero
uh but that was an interesting bet um
and then in 2019 and 2020 i did a bunch
more like 10 or 15 but it's
it's been too early to really say what's
going to work but i did figma
clubhouse house uh the aperitif brand
uh circle this new crater community
thing
um squad like but just a bunch of small
smaller small ones uh that are just so
early to really know if they're going to
work or not
um but i have some sort of like some
track record and like
some interest in really learning about
about this
this kind of space because it's it's
fundamentally important like if you're
interested in startups like a lot of the
startups do raise capital they do raise
money from vcs and angels
and and there aren't that many people
who are those people and so like
you can be a meaningful part of like
business creation engine
uh you know if you participate in that
so that's kind of how i thought about it
and then
i did after the george floyd stuff i
i there was that meme going around about
higher
wire and i was like i can do these i
could hire people
and i did and we'll continue to do so
and i can also write checks and so
i just tweeted out this is the power of
twitter uh you know i just tweeted out
hey i've
done some of these investments i'm
looking for more i'd love to invest in
black founders
and i did four deals from that and two
others since
indirectly um and basically i just run
out of ran out of money like i can't
i don't again i don't have picture stock
i don't i'm not
uh you know i still pay myself like a
salary i haven't sort of exited any
liquidity
on the government stock side so it's not
like i have a ton of money
um but you know i did a few deals and i
and some of them were looking for more
money so i emailed a few friends
including the ball i was like hey
i did a couple deals you know you want
to co-invest in these they're looking
for more
more money and he he effectively just
says you know like i'd love to just give
you money and then you can just choose
where you want to invest in i'll pay you
to do that and help you sort of advise
you on that
uh so like let me know if you're
interested like we have this new product
angel list called rolling funds sort of
like lowers the barrier of entry as a
as a fund manager you can sort of try it
out ping a few friends i'll
anchor you you know you can start at
like a hundred thousand dollars a
quarter do a couple deals a quarter and
then you know
see how it goes and you can use twitter
you can do whatever you want because
it's kind of this new model
um that's a little different than how
it's been done in the past and i was
like oh this is interesting like i'm not
going to be a full-time vc
i don't want to deal with any of that
stuff but i don't have the time i don't
want to go on like this
road show for months uh or zoom show now
and uh but i can you know i can send
some emails and these things right so i
so i talked to angellist set up like a
little rolling fund and
uh put together a brief memo on an ocean
that's just sort of like my track record
who i
am like what i'm interested in uh my
little fun strategy and just send it out
to
you know 50 100 people did a webinar
about it a couple tweets and now i have
over a million dollars a quarter
committed
so it'll be it's a sizable it's a
sizable fund it'll be a four million
dollar a year fund or something like
that which you know if you have a
normal fund with all these different
things that's sort of the equivalent of
like a 12 million 20 million dollar fund
depending on how much you allocate for
follow-ons and
next week walk us through the math um i
know you've done the math in terms of
like how that works but
walk us through like if you raised a 40
million dollar fund previously like
we're talking earlier
yeah do the math how that works yeah i
mean i was kind of mind blown because
even though i'd raised money from vcs
and things and been an angel like i
never really
knew what what are the economics of the
vc right and so i
yeah i was like 40 million dollar fund
that
is you know first of all you're not
investing the 40 million you take a
typically take a 2
management fee over 10 years so that's
20 gone so you're really investing 32
million dollars
then typically half of that or
two-thirds of that is often reserved for
follow-on capital for this sort of the
first rounds of these companies
they're second and third etcetera rounds
uh typically it's pretty common
one it one to one or one to two ratio so
let's speak conservatives let's say one
to one
so that's half the capital so 16 million
is going into early stage first rounds
of these companies
and then that's over many years often
right so that might be over
three years typically right three to
five years or something like that for a
fun of that size
so really that 16 million dollars is
split over three years it's around five
million dollars a year
right so this 40 million dollar fund
that i see this big announcement i'm
like wow i would never do that that's
insanely massive and like it's
good probably so wealthy and making all
this money and they can do all these
deals
you know and i'm like wait that's like
[ __ ] like five and a half million bucks
five point three three three million a
year into new companies
like that's that's that's a very
different like five to fif
40 that's a huge difference right so i
just started doing the math and i was
like wow like i can
with the rolling fund which like
dramatically makes it easier for me to
to do this and because of twitter and
the sort of
the sort of direct to sort of invest lp
kind of relationship i can have with
everybody
uh because that's kind of my stick like
i can raise a fund that's you know
probably on the size of a lot of these
early stage funds but it's part time for
me
i can and i don't have any overhead
right 100 of my management fee i'm just
putting back into the company into the
fund is lp capital
so you know of the 4.4 or whatever i'm
at now per year like
you know basically besides angel lists
fees that's all going to go to companies
uh so over 4 million dollars will go
straight to the companies
uh and uh and and that's
it right you know like it just keeps the
model incredibly simple you don't have
to do any math on like
any costs to the to the fund in terms of
like dinners or
employees or associates or an office
space or any of that stuff like i don't
need any of that right like all i need
is
um some money goes into an ageless bank
account and then i
talk to companies and say hey can i give
you money and then if they say yes
i just you know do a cc and then the
deal gets done and i think that is going
to be really interesting over the next
few years like kind of being early
that same idea i just i just like as i
when i
discovered this and i talked to naval
about it i was like i was like this is
really interesting and like i totally
imagine in five years
there are going to be hundreds of these
people like what i'm doing now who are
having these rolling fonts able to
collect you know
commits on a quarterly basis able to do
it publicly raise
any time raise anywhere and
you you know like i wonder what that
does to like sort of traditional
sandhill road clearly sandal road's out
of commission right now with
covid right but like i wonder if like
this is just the end of it
right like why would you why would you
need to if you can just raise from all
these people
you can do it over resume you no founder
wants to raise money
right like even if if you're you want to
go down the vc route
it's a necessary evil still right uh and
so i just think
if you can if you can get coalitions of
these
founders operators people who actually
understand
sort of what it is to be a founder or
have some domain expertise
uh i i just think that that sort of the
career vc again
like it's a curve it's not like a binary
instance
it's on its way out it's been on its way
out for a long time you saw this with
syndicates you saw this with super
angels
you saw this now with rolling funds my
guess is over time the sort of
traditional partnership
model is going to go away uh
and you see it in politics right like i
think politics is a really interesting
analogy because you have
bernie sanders and trump who basically
can race
directly from people they don't have
their their teams are tiny they have
incredibly low overhead
they're super scalable and they they can
use it
as a as a marketing thing like i don't
have to do super pacs i don't have to
have dinners with rich people behind
closed doors
every two years which is what vcs do
right
like that's what vc's have this like
two-year fundraising kind of
process they talk to all these rich
people
you know that i don't i still don't know
most of their names like i kind of
people have been like oh you should you
know and i'm like oh i didn't even know
there are all these people out here
a lot of them you know they're like
they're like family offices
a lot of them are in like china like the
money it's not as
it's not as like sort of like a bunch of
tech people giving other tech people
money there's a there's a
there there's a lot more happening uh
that i've sort of started learning about
but you know a lot of them have access
right so like you know if if if
some family office writes you a 10
million dollar check into your fund to
anchor you
like you're gonna have to you know give
them updates right you're gonna have to
kind of give them some things have a
call with them
once a month which is actually not that
dissimilar probably from politics right
like there's probably some soft
commitment
that if you if you bundle and you get
you know
you give the you know the clinton
campaign or the biden campaign or the
trump campaign or whatever like
a million bucks they're gonna pick up
the phone call
right uh and so there's like interesting
to see
that kind of play out so my guess is
just like in politics you're going to
see way more aocs way more bernie's way
more trumps
right uh i don't know if that's good or
bad like not a
statement on that just it's just gonna
happen like that's what i believe
and that's the beauty of democracy and
like that you're just going to get
demo you know people want democracy and
they're going to get right inevitably
uh and uh and i think the same thing
will happen on the on the venture side
which by the way
i think you know this whole conversation
about diversity and inclusion
like a lot of founders they race from
vcs these vc's raised from lps these lps
look
very you know there's a there's a path
right uh
uh you know that sort of that cuts
through harvard and stanford and i think
if you can have all of these fund
managers from all over the place from
all different backgrounds
and all the levels of domain expertise
all having these
small funds you know like that's just
better
for everybody it's like more diverse lps
more diverse founders more diverse gps
more diverse employees like i i see this
all the time like i'm
you know a dude i like started a company
and like
people you know like like women will be
like you know it's weird that like this
company i worked at like did this or
didn't do that and i was like holy crap
i had no idea i didn't even know
that's the thing that women would want
or not want or whatever you know i just
had so little context for it
uh like tampons in the bathroom like
it's so cool and i'm like oh [ __ ] that's
a great idea
like i didn't i wouldn't have thought of
that obviously i was 21 at the time a
little different life experience now so
i know some of these things but
but uh i just think it's so much better
to just give people
money to go solve the problems that they
already know about and try to spend all
this time
you know trying to like learn about this
thing it's like no i'd just rather give
you money and you can go solve it right
and i think the same thing with these
with this sort of like the venture
capital kind of community is like all
these
all these funds are trying to do all
these things but i really think the
answer is just like give people
a bunch of money and then like they'll
do it they'll do a great job they'll do
a better job than you reading 10 books
and a bunch of blog posts
and then trying to solve the problem
like that you just don't know it's not
it's like like i can talk about indian
culture i've never lived in india
but like i just know it because i've
i've learned i just grew up in that
sort of environment right uh and and
just
it doesn't matter how awesome you are
and like unless you have like a
a master's degree you're just not going
to know as much as i do because of all
the little things i picked up
and it's kind of like that right and so
i just believe so much in like
a bunch of diverse lps picking a bunch
of diverse
gps and those gps picking a bunch of
diverse founders and those founders
building companies that are just better
at all these other things solving all of
these different problems
and i'm just i'm super excited about it
because i do think it's going to be like
a really interesting trend that's going
to lead to a lot of interesting
interesting companies in the next you
know five to ten years
one of the most popular questions these
two are kind of related that i got when
i asked for
questions to talk to you about was uh
sitting in the investor seat now how you
think about product market fit
and evaluating that right as an investor
versus an operator and
let's start there that we can get into
there's another question about community
building versus product development but
just
in the investor seat how do you think
about product market fit maybe either
similarly or differently than you would
as an operator
yeah i mean i really think about product
market fit there's there's two types of
there's sort of two distinct businesses
people typically build there's like b2b
businesses and b2c businesses right
uh and i think like i have much more
context on the b2c side
even though gumroad is kind of a b2b ish
company the critter economy kind of is a
little bit murky in the middle
but the way i think about it is do
people use this
that's sort of number one and then do
these people share it with other people
right um be this b2b it's even simpler
it's like do these people pay for your
service
uh and it's surprising to me how
sort of how little like one how easy it
feels like it should be to get to that
but then how hard it actually is in
practice and so i think i
i'm hopefully going to have a superpower
like we were one of the first users of
abstract first hundred users or
something like that
um and that's sort of with a bunch of
different startups just because we were
an early tech company
so we would honestly we'd constantly use
stuff right like figma and notion and
slack
all of these kind of things because we
needed to solve problems right and so i
hope to have like a really good
kind of insight into one picking the
right people because i can
see oh they're gonna solve this problem
because as someone who needs this
problem solved like i'm
waiting with my credit card here right
and if i don't
have that inclination i'm not gonna
invest it's like i'm either gonna be a
customer and an investor or neither
right sort of no conflict no interest
uh so that's i think a big one on the
b2b side i think on the b to c
side i think people really like i saw
this at pinterest i really believe in
clubhouse
i think it's going to work uh and and
the reason is like you get a sense of
like
the the way that the sort of behavior
pattern of someone who uses this
product and the fact that they want all
of their friends on it
right now and not only do they want that
but they're actually going to go do it
right like there are all these decks and
all these things i get that are like oh
we have these metrics and this and that
but like
it's just clear that like they don't
really have like that profound
like i need to get my friend on this
platform and like i think
people don't realize how hard that is in
in the sense that like when they see it
in a little you know a couple instances
of that they put it in their deck and
they put it like a testimony on there
they think that's what it is
but really it's like literally it's like
coronavirus like everyone that gets it
gives it to somebody else kind of thing
right like that's what virality
virus right like is and so like
pinterest i saw that with
17 000 users doing 60 million page views
a month like just the engagement was
insane
i saw that in instagram when they
launched you know
i see that with clubhouse now where it's
like everyone that joins is like i need
i know
immediately who to bring on next and i
think
nothing reaches scale without that
especially on the consumer side right
because
otherwise you're spending money to grow
right and so you're just not going to
get to billions of people without
you know 100 million people telling you
know 900 million people and
the 10 million telling 100 the 90
million and then the 1 million telling
the 9 million
et cetera et cetera right um and so i
think i hope to have like pretty good
intuition both on the consumer side and
on the b2b side
um and i can also help them right
because as
gumroad i can literally pay for the
service integrate them and say look this
is not
where it needs to be like if i was like
i'm going to cancel i'm not going to pay
for this
um i think that's good like i really
believe in ocean i think
ocean will be a you know 20 billion
dollar company someday because
it's so essential to government that's
it like i have no idea
anything about the company but like
one more thing like i don't think people
understand like if i use a product like
let's say it's the governor ceo i find a
product online because i have a problem
i google for it i go to their homepage i
read their thing i sign up
i integrate it like which requires
writing some code
like putting that in you know into our
sort of security process getting that
deployed making sure it works
you know getting all that code peer
reviewed before that
and then paying for paying for it right
and getting value out of it
enough that i'm continuing to pay for it
that is an insanely hard thing to do
and which means it's an insanely high
signal like every time that happens i'm
going to email the company and be like
hey can i put 250k into this company
right because it's so rare and it's also
so indicative
because it's so rare the companies that
get there it means you
you basically solve the problem so well
and the problem was so
was so it needed to be solved so badly
that i just went through that whole
funnel right
uh without talking to a single human
being which i think is like an
incredibly
a good signal for for a company if you
can do that
right like i i should have when i
started using stripe and like i accepted
my first payment on stripe i should have
been like can i please
give you ten thousand dollars because i
didn't realize at that time like how
how significant it was because as a user
that's all i was doing
because obviously if i didn't use the
service i didn't use the service so
every service i used i had to go through
that flow to kind of do it
but like i used twilio i used stripe i
used sendgrid
like these you know at the time these
were all worth you know low hundreds of
millions if that
in valuation right um and so i'm hopeful
that like just being in the game
is gonna give you insights like when i
when when you know when i meet
with with uh with certain people like
you know they're like it was obvious
like we had the internal numbers we were
in the in the thing like pinterest was
obvious
and i just think vc is when you operate
at this like distant level you just
don't know you're like looking at
different things you're looking at like
how beautiful the homepage is or like
how awesome the team is
or like the name and the domain and like
these other signals like their twitter
follower account and like the quality of
the content
like it's like a it's like a
peer-reviewed it's like an academic view
of it right it's like people being like
oh this is interesting because
donald trump isn't like a you know a
career politician has this and doesn't
do this so obviously he's not to win
but that's like the wrong view because
the right view is
what does the market want the market
doesn't give a crap about any of this
other stuff
like you can have typos all over the
homepage you could have a thing that's
laggy
it doesn't work in internet explorer all
these things that developers might be
up on you about but it's like well
people are paying for it
you know people people need it badly
right like only fans is like a terrible
product
but it's growing like crazy it will
probably be the largest company in this
whole space
uh because there's a use there's a need
for that
kind of thing especially right now with
cobit and people needing to make money
and like
it's not that great of a product and
guess what doesn't even need to be
they will probably be you know
processing hundreds of millions billions
of dollars a year pretty soon uh
and that's i think the takeaway from
that blog post right there was that line
that went viral which is
it doesn't matter how amazing your team
is or how fast you ship features the
market you're in is going to determine
most your growth which i still believe
and i think it really resonated because
there are all these people
who built these phenomenal products and
it was like not enough and then there
are all these people
who honestly build terrible products and
twitter is a great example of this right
like twitter has succeeded despite
itself
in my opinion like i feel like they made
so many mistakes so many blunders the
fail whale
they were down all the time they still
don't have like
certain functionality that people expect
uh
but the truth is the market needs it's
just so valuable
to people that you know it's going to
succeed
it's going to succeed in despite of all
of its failings
and then you have other i know plenty of
companies that are phenomenal teams
phenomenal products like just beautiful
and then no one uses them right uh
because the thing
like the market didn't care and and so i
think it's just like really being
diligent about like does the market
really want this
problem solved and the answer is often
like no the market works right this is
kind of the lindy thing
it's working everyone's living like
coronavirus
is has also not like stopped people from
doing what they like to do
it's people are just gonna do what they
do and so they're pretty happy with
what's
what the current state of the world is
right they're like they're living in it
they're not
maybe looking all day long for like new
software to use
right and so so i i think people
underestimate like how hard it is to
reach product market fit and then also
how
how once you reach it literally like
nothing else
really matters like at that point you're
just scaling right
so this gets at this question of like
community development
versus product development right and i
think that there's
a bare bones like set of quality that
you have to have on the product side
like the product has to
work it might not have been perfect but
it's got to work and be functional
um but twitter's you know one example
there's many others of like
part of twitter's magic is the product
and how it works
but then there's the community side and
it's the people who are there and the
content they're sharing and kind of all
of the
the non-product features to it how do
you think about that balance especially
in the earliest stages of a business
um and just kind of when do you optimize
for the product building
versus more of like the community or the
non-product type features that end up
pulling people in and holding them there
and making it valuable for somebody
yeah i mean i think that's super
essential especially on the b2c side
because the truth is you can you can
send someone a message on slack
on twitter on whatsapp on facebook on
facebook messenger post on their wall
like there's there's like hundreds of
ways if i wanted to send you a message
email you
etc but each one has a different
connotation
right like it has a different meaning it
has like a different place in our
society
and our etiquette and so i think that's
why consumer is so difficult is because
people build the products they're
focusing like the y combinator make
something people want and everyone
obsesses about the something
like we got to make something awesome
but it's like the people right
that's super key and and and really
figuring out i think
who you're building for who's going to
benefit the most from this
right like who who's really has like the
deep deep pain
like who's going to use this first
because they need it solved so badly
and then the rest of the world will sort
of slowly catch up over time uh
and figuring out like the demographics
of that right and and and
a community i think simply is just a
group of people that have something in
common
right so if you find out what that group
of people is
they will have something in common they
will be a community by default right
building for everybody is just not
something anyone does
because just not you know less than half
the world speaks any language right so
you're already starting with like a max
of like a billion two billion people or
whatever when you build the most broad
platform ever like coke
might have four billion customers or
something right ever
and nobody else does right no tech tech
company does
um so i think it's it's it's i was on a
bread actually from first round about
this he's like so many startups
they don't even know who their customer
is they still like they know they saw
the problem
and then it's like okay who has this
problem and then it's just like
really difficult to even stripe in the
early days it's like people are like oh
this is for developers right but like
uber and airbnb they're not going to use
stripe like they're going to use
off net or like data you know first data
or like one of these
core things and like square right square
was like
for farmers markets and like you know
like you just no one knows like you
think you know the right people but
you just you know you don't really it
takes a long time to really figure i'm a
shopify right they were a public company
at a billion dollars
and it's like oh this is for snowboards
and like you know like selling this kind
of stuff and then like
you know tens of millions hundreds of
millions in gmd
businesses are now on shopify and it
does i mean shopify could probably power
macy's at this point right and probably
will in like five years
uh and so i think i think people like
sort of
don't really have a clear view of of who
the right customer
is uh and i think pinterest we did that
really well with like sort of midwestern
moms and things like that
uh you know ben was really savvy about
figuring that out i think clubhouse has
done a really good job of like kind of
sort of like built yeah it sucks if
you're not part of it but like they're
really just
careful about growing the community over
time because i do think it matters
i do think people think oh you can just
solve the problem and then it's great
but it's like no you need to know
twitter needed to know
it's for this group of people in the
early days some stacking snows for this
group of people in the early days
um and and it's also like a an overhead
problem too right because if you
don't get the right people even though
they could use it you now have to train
all these new people
they use it very differently they're
affecting the norms in this way
um there's like a cultural inertia that
builds up and you want to make sure that
that is going in the right direction
before you onboard all these people
otherwise it's gonna they're gonna shift
it into this other thing that you really
don't want
right like patreon for example they see
only fans they see the crazy growth and
they've made a conscious decision
saying we don't want to go that route we
don't you know we that's not what we
want and patreon is big enough that they
can kind of do that
but if you know patreon just got started
and it just became the default for this
kind of thing like
they wouldn't be able to stop it right
if that makes sense like there's sort of
like the
the parasite becomes the host kind of
thing right
like you want to maintain that um but
yeah that's kind of how i think about it
i do think like to your point there's
this interesting shift you can now do
that wasn't really possible five to ten
years ago which is you can actually
build an
audience before you have a product and
that's super fascinating
because you can actually really figure
out who who
cares about you who are your super fans
what problems do they have
uh you know and then they already know
like yeah i'm waiting for him to build
it like this is the right person to
build the thing we're all waiting for
them to build the thing
i mean it's even like this venture firm
i'm doing right like it kind of came out
of nowhere but i think it's because i
built a community
of followers and founders and other
investors and designers and engineers
and writers who
a lot of them followed me because of
this journey that i went through they
want to kind of go through a similar
thing
and like a big part of that journey
might be for some people certainly not
all or even most but
for that some of them it's like i need
some money to get started and so
now i can go do that i can kind of if
you know i think my fund might be a
great example of like a community first
kind of
business or product right like i didn't
go out i wasn't like i need to be a vc i
want to be a vc right
it was like oh there are all these
people that i want to give money to
and they're all these people who want to
give money to people that but they don't
know they don't you can't like they
don't know who these people are like
and i can go connect that i can i'm like
a one-man marketplace
effectively right uh and so yeah no i
think it's a
and and really that's a lot of consumer
products like they're really
marketplaces right they're like creators
and consumers and you're trying to kind
of connect them to
to each other i want to switch gears and
talk a little bit about
crypto and bitcoin what are your
thoughts there you told a uh
amazing story earlier of a random person
an airbnb named brian who
ended up being the founder of coinbase
uh reaching out to you
but uh what's kind of been your journey
with bitcoin and crypto and kind of
where do you sit with it now
yeah i bought a bunch not that early
unfortunately
but i have i have some uh i think
i i really do believe that crypto will
change everything
uh i just think it's like who knows when
right it's kind of like that kind of
tinkering thing like clearly it's
at least to me it seems whenever you
have that many smart people interested
in something
it's really an inevitability it's like a
bunch of people thinking about
food science or any of these things like
it's going to happen
like clearly there's something here
climate change etc like there's there's
there's like something with within smart
people that's kind of driving them to
this area
uh and i just don't know when yeah i
mean i i
i think the difficulty with with
something like crypto is it's so
fundamental
like you you kind of have to build
rebuild everything in crypto in this new
model because you kind of it's like when
gumroad went from like the
you know the vc back to the non i had to
go down to zero
you're kind of you have to kind of like
build like new nation states and new
cities
and new sort of economic infrastructure
and new
you know regulations and new everything
effectively to kind of
a new police force that you know like
all of these things have to be thought
of in a very different way
and i think it's inevitable like i
really believe like anything that looks
the same
pre-internet and post-internet is just
is sort of
is not going to look the same for for
much longer right like the internet is
software's eating the world it's sort of
like going to change everything that it
touches eventually
because it's just so fundamental as an
innovation
uh as an invention and and i mean like i
can look outside my window and like
everything looks roughly the same as it
looked
40 years ago you know there's like roads
and there's
fences and there's cars with four wheels
and there's a pool
and there's you know buildings or
whatever and like telephone poles right
and like
that's not that's not going to be the
view outside my window 50 years from now
right there's going to be like drones
flying around
and like weird-looking car things and
like i don't know who know you know like
i'm sure all of this
a lot of this stuff is just going to go
away like there might not be roads we
might just
who knows i don't know uh but my guess
is that all the
all of this stuff is going to change and
in a world like going back to that
liquidity thing i just think increased
liquidity is so
so important and i think what crypto
does is it just massively increases
liquidity because it allows
everyone to become a financial player
and that sort of to transact
directly all the time uh and
yeah i think you know people always talk
about like taxes like taxation is theft
or whatever right and like
but if you think about it like a huge
amount of america's is sort of
credit card based and every credit card
transaction has
roughly two to three percent uh
tacked on to it right and so that's a
two to three percent tax that like
effectively all of us are paying every
time we use
postmates or uber which by the way like
is a much larger percentage of our
economy than it's ever been
uh and so i just think like clearly
that's a middleman that will go away
eventually
like it's just an inevitability to me
that that will
you know that will go away i mean
someone who runs gumroad i mean i see it
i'm like yeah obviously there's going to
be a future where
you know you can go to any website and
pay the person directly like you
wouldn't even pay governor right you
would pay the creator directly and then
gumroad
because we're facilitating it you know
there'd be a sort of a smart contract or
something that would allow us to get
this you know this kind of thing uh some
percent or whatever
it's just it's just inevitable like i i
think in the future gumroad won't even
need to exist
you know because like it will become so
liquid that even the middlemen that we
disintermediated
we will be a middle man that gets
disintermediated like
that's inevitable to me uh and that's
great that's a good thing i'm not
attached i don't need to be
like if we can solve the problem to a
point where we don't need to exist like
that's
awesome right like that would be great
for me and help me
help me understand how you guys have
thought about that uh in terms of like
take bitcoin for example
yeah accept bitcoin don't accept bitcoin
have you tried it before
just a dollar like how has that been
yeah we just currently just stick to
dollars i think the the biggest issue we
have with
with supporting bitcoin is everyone that
wants bitcoin wants to get paid in
bitcoin
that's the issue that we have is like we
get creators all day long that are like
hey we want crypto and i'm like all you
got to do is find me five people that
want to pay in bitcoin and i'll build it
because the truth is
everyone wants it no one wants to give
it
right uh and so i think that's sort of
like
the problem with bitcoin is it is so
interesting and it is so
it's sort of an investment vehicle right
uh
for for folks that like it doesn't have
it's not like usd or something where and
i know there's sort of like usd coins
and stuff like that that i think are
interesting too
but i think that that's sort of like the
fundamental issue is that people
people there's this like supply demand
problem where everyone wants it no one
wants to give it to anybody else no one
wants to be the person who bought a
pizza for
you know one bitcoin or 50 bitcoin or
whatever it was
uh and so i think there's that sort of
risk aversion that everyone is kind of
very
fearful of so i mean it might not even
be bitcoin it might be like
a new fork or something like that that
kind of you know solves some of these
other problems
but i do i still i still believe it's
inevitable right and that might require
like the browsers that we use to be
different and like
you know like the there but it seems
yeah
what i tell people is like when my mom
wants to pay with bitcoin i'm sold
right like the minute again like the
market wants what it wants
and the minute the market wants to pay
with bitcoin like we'll support it
you know the next day and my guess is
we'll support apple pay and other things
that would just
we won't even have to think about it
eventually that like it just is handled
by stripe or apple or whatever and it's
just a part of
the nature of doing business uh and i'm
just really fascinated like i
actually think one of the things this is
like kind of a tangent but one of the
things i'm really interested in with
self-driving cars
is is the sort of uh the nexus
problem right which is basically if you
start if everyone has self-driving
cars my my guess is people are going to
be a lot more
mobile and going to move around a lot
more like for example if you're an nba
player you basically have to file taxes
in like 50 states or whatever right
because
you're sort of making revenue and doing
your job in all these different places
and there's people that just like do
this for nba players right
and every sort of athlete uh and and
eventually if we're selling driving cars
and sort of like other future
uh this new future like that's gonna
happen that
that's gonna happen to a lot more people
and you're going to have to start
collecting taxes like right now for
example you can get a bunch of stock
in california working in california and
then you can like move to florida and
then the company ipos and you
you pay no taxes to florida right or
whatever um
and so like that's an inefficiency in
the market that will eventually get
resolved and my guess
is that like one of the accelerants to
that is going to be all these people
moving around all the time and
a lot of these transactions are going to
have to be kind of like at point of sale
right where it's like where were you at
the time and the way that you know that
sort of tax and all these things are
collected that's all visible on that
transaction it's not per transaction
amount it's not like
every once a year you pay your taxes
kind of thing
uh i believe at some point that will be
the future we live in
uh and the the really interesting thing
about that is then you can unbundle the
government right because you can
actually see like oh this is
it's not just like all this money going
into like this account and then the fed
kind of decides what they want to do
with it it's really like oh you paid for
coffee at this place this much goes
to the city this much goes to the county
this much goes to the you know to the
fed
or not even the fed directly but it goes
directly into
you know this the military or like
you know uh department of homeland
security or whatever it is
and then people should be able to see
that right because i think people don't
have problem paying taxes it's just like
when you walk down the road and you see
a bunch of construction you have no idea
what the hell is going on
it's like that opaqueness that i think
irritates people people were like oh
this is cool this is like what the
government like
what i get for this this money great
right
uh i think it would be great but but i
think yeah that whole crypto
it feels to me like a fundamental
importance like i was reading this book
about
uh the genome and like you know like
the sort of bodies are bodies are kind
of a decentralized they feel centralized
but like there's sort of this
decentralized like bottoms up approach
to solving problems that
has taken billions of years right and
and they're very efficient like
decentralized bottoms up sort of
organisms or companies or whatever are
much are much better at solving problems
because they're sort of anti-fragile
like the head can get cut off and these
other things can keep going
and and you don't have this problem
where you have someone who sort of
builds power over time
and sort of like it's trying you know
it's sort of in service of themselves
the whole organism etc right um and so i
just really believe that
humanity in the future if we want to get
to whatever the paragon
of civilization is it will be
decentralized right it's like the
fundamental problem with communism is
you have to have someone who enforces
equality very like how do you that's
kind of oxymoronic
and the only way you can really do that
is by literally never giving anyone that
much power
it has to just be built into the model
that like no one can do
certain things in my opinion uh and i'm
sure they're
experts and i'm getting a lot of this
wrong and i don't really know what i'm
talking about
but like that idea is really interesting
to me that sort of decentralized
bottoms up sort of and the internet's
gonna allow for that right because
like before you kind of needed the
bundling because you needed the
economies of scale to kind of solve
certain problems at certain scale but if
you can really
increase the liquidity and the
transparency and everyone can see
everything
uh i just think just like you would have
a startup that solves a problem with
five people or one person instead of 100
or
200 right because you don't have to give
dvds and deal with
shipping fulfillment and like all of
these things are just handled by other
people
and those people make more money than
they would if they were working at your
own company that's kind of like firm
outside inside or firm thing uh it's
just going to be better
it's just going to lead to a much more
efficient sort of system
uh systems of government governance you
know
everyone's gonna be safer like i i just
think ultimately
like a decentralized something is gonna
be better than the decentralized version
of it
right just like the internet is better
than like your
local library or something like that
right like the you're getting
billions of people to curate for you
instead of like three
right i think that you're more right
than wrong right i mean all the the
details are where the nuances but but
for sure i think that you're more right
than wrong
um before i get into the rapid fire sort
of questions
uh somebody asked what is some popular
advice that you
hear often that you think is wrong or it
sucks like what what is the advice that
gets shared
all the time and you think people maybe
shouldn't actually listen to it or it's
misleading yeah i i think there's
it's it's ironic because i feel like i
helped contribute to this
uh but there's this like make a living
doing what you love right there's a
critter economy
i think gumroad we kind of invented the
term make a living doing what you love
not that that really means anything but
uh
there's i think there's this idea that
like you should only pursue the things
that you love
and are passionate about uh you know
like the boss is like you you know find
the thing that you
that you do endlessly effortlessly or
whatever
and i i think there are things like that
for some people but there are a lot of
things that i think i'm really good at
and i love doing but it's like the co
it's a cause and effect switch
it's like i am really good at doing it
which is why i love doing it
but there was a period of time where i
wasn't good at it and i kind of pushed
through
and it became good at it and then
started like i loved the idea of it and
i knew that if i got good enough at it
i would also i would just love it
entirely if that makes sense right like
there's just
like growth is uncomfortable right like
your body
doesn't like to expend energy doesn't
need to expand right
sort of like survival of the the fitness
or whatever right like it's sort of a
defense mechanism
and you know just in case and uh and i
think the same thing with a lot of you
like you don't need to learn how to
paint you don't need to learn
these skills to survive and so i think
it does hurt
and so i think there's like sometimes
this rhetoric especially because the
successful people often
are the ones that say it all the time
right but are like no you should only do
what you love and only work this much
and like
you should prioritize your family and
your friends and
ultimately there is like a sort of a two
marshmallow kind of thing right like
ultimately
you do probably want to work a little
bit harder than most people do
if you want to get to some point and you
might not like doing a lot of the things
right like i think being a solo founder
was like the best thing ever because i
had to learn
everything like starting this fun yeah
there's like a lot of weird stuff that i
don't care about
but like i learned those things and
those things
inherently because they're annoying and
to learn like very few people learn them
and so like i can talk about this kind
of fun stuff
and like teach people and gain an
audience from doing that and founders
like me for doing that and i might they
might
want to let me onto their you know cap
table because of that and so i just
think it's like
it's sort of beneficial um but yeah
there's just there's
there's just like this rhetoric i think
that like you need to love
all the bits of it like writing no dude
like right
suck sometimes man like i'll stare at
this thing be like i don't want to do
this i don't like doing it
but but but then i post something and it
does really well and everyone loves it
and it feels amazing
and the worry i have is that people
think that that is like
that that that was like a labor like
just love it was just like oh i love you
know it's like no it's like brutal like
working through this thing
outlining it re-editing it like they
don't see the seven eight nine drafts of
like oh
this didn't work it wasn't effortless at
all actually for me very like it was
brutally difficult
and it got better and i could see and i
had the confidence because i'd done it
before that i would get through it
eventually
uh but yeah i just think there's that
that kind of like that advice that
people share because it sounds good but
it's like no sometimes you just
you know you just need to spend a couple
years you know
being bad i think that's fair
uh two questions and then you get to ask
me one to wrap up
the first is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
i really liked uh how to win friends and
influence people
which has a terrible title but i loved
that book
maybe it's just because i was not a good
person like before i read that book or
something some people are like this is
all
obvious i was like damn my bad
uh but i really like that book i think
it really helped me think about like
other people in my conversations you
know like you it's so easy to
like you like you have a different
person it's like when you hear yourself
talk right like
you realize like oh my gosh like i'm a
very different person
like i'm inverted like there are all
these things about the way
other people sort of like interface with
me that i've never thought about and
that book really like helped me think
about like oh wow like i'm actually
i'm just like an npc in somebody else's
story right like they don't think about
me like
like i know all these things going
around in my head and sort of my
environment
and it just really made me aware that
like i really
don't matter to anybody else like i'm
like a little person that gives them a
quest or gives them some money or
whatever
but they're they're they're they care
about them right and maybe a couple
other people but
their family or something like that so
that that book i think really helped me
kind of like
sort of like get humble i guess about it
and be like no my
my job is to like provide value and then
like go on my way and i don't have to
like
pretend that it's some grand
relationship that we have
you know it's been really freeing it
it's one of the best books in the world
and most popular for a reason for sure
uh aliens believer or non-believer
i am definitely a believer yeah i i
you'd have to be so cocky to think that
that there's only one of one planet
and where the we you got lucky you know
it's like it's like when you win the
lottery or something you know just like
no like there's probably
my guess is that there are there are a
lot of them uh
they might be really far away uh
but man i yeah i just want to be hopeful
man like you know like
i imagine that like thinking about the
sort of the crazy future
right like what it you know like there
was a time where like we were
discovering new
human beings on earth like how crazy
would that be
to like just be like holy crap there's
like a whole
group of people here that are like us
that we like but in other ways are
totally not and speak a different
language and all these things
and like my guess is how cool would it
be to have that happen
on an interstellar level right like at
some point in the future
to like and that would be freaking scary
i mean i can't imagine like how
nerve-wracking that would be for both
you know like if
if we get there but like i don't know
i'm hopeful for that happening at some
point in the future
it would be amazing i i feel like we
need to start thinking about is it uh
are we gonna discover the aliens or the
aliens gonna discover us
uh you get you could ask me one question
to finish up what do you got for me
yeah i mean how do you think about i
mean you do so many different types of
content which is awesome
like how do you like have you thought
about like what's next in terms of like
the
type type of content and like how you
yeah like how do you think about
exploring you know new mediums and
things like that especially with covet
and like
yeah i think that there's like major
inflection points so like
audio was one right there's kind of this
resurgence on video you see spotify
adding like
video podcasts which is really just a
video uh
youtube's kind of you know popular you
get the tick tocks and things like that
so
the major ones i think are what people
really focus on because they're the easy
ones to see
but the micro um kind of evolutions if
you will in content i think are much
more interesting and actually that's
where a lot of the value gets captured
so if you think about um in written form
right now
like you've got eric stromberg um doing
these like screenshot essays
right and then patrick o'shaughnessy
with invest like the best like they've
now incorporated it
um and they're calling on business cards
right but there's just this idea
of like hey wait a second there's
something between a tweet and like a
blog post
and it literally fits all on the screen
of an iphone right and like that's
that's a pretty interesting like nuanced
thing if you look at
you know audio you could say all of the
podcasts and like that whole rise
well clubhouse is kind of like a micro
kind of
live drop-in version of really kind of a
podcast and
you know conference call kind of mixed
together or whatever
and so as you kind of go through the
micro pieces of these types of content
it just feels like that's where a lot of
the the value gets captured
what i think is much harder to to
understand is um
when it relates to content like where
are the platforms that are going to
accrue a lot of the value versus
kind of the non-venture-backable type
just content providers right so the
screenshot essays
not really a venture-backable type
business but
if there was a platform that then
aggregated them all and created a
marketplace and a follow graph and i
mean like
okay like there's a there's something
else there and so i think that it's you
gotta
see the micro evolution happen in a
certain
type of media format and then really
look like the platform type companies
um but at the end of the day like i i
think you and i see very kind of eye to
eye on
i call them personal media companies
where people just build these massive
audiences
maybe multi-platform or may not be uh
and then they're going to go and they're
going to create products
right and whether that's a physical
product like you see you know kind of
youtube star selling merchandise or you
see people actually creating software
or you see the kim kardashians and kylie
jenner's creating
makeup like they're going to sell
products through that audience and uh
and as they do that i think you're gonna
see really really valuable companies get
built over time
how do you think about gpt3 to throw
another question
so i'm not technical right and so
in kind of a at a high level like it
looks like magic
as you kind of unpack more and more of
kind of the use cases and you see
everything from the
you know learn from anyone or the figma
design you know all these kind of
applications we've also can find around
on twitter
um it feels like we're teetering on the
edge
of being able to use this stuff in
production for real products built on
top of it
but we maybe we're not quite there yet
like we're really really damn close and
i think that's why everyone's kind of
like leaning in and excited about it
um the other piece of it uh to me that's
really interesting is
can you basically start to use it to uh
to put in people's hands so they can
start using it for things you and i
can't
imagine right so already like i've seen
five or six demos online or prototypes
or like i would have never thought of
that
right and so it's like you know you kind
of talked about it earlier it's just
like
we don't know what it becomes and so
just like get it in as many
different types of people's hands as
possible and like
just let them like go to work right and
then you and i will turn around be like
whoa did you see this or did you see
that and we'll be like and that's pretty
cool and
that's how i think real innovation and
value gets uh gets created
awesome yeah i agree i have no idea i
see it i'm like this is crazy
i would love to integrate into gumroad
somehow i don't know what it looks like
but
yeah it's gonna be like obvious you know
like a year from now it's like oh of
course that's the
absolutely where where can we send
people to find you online learn more
about gumroad or
uh or the investing um side yeah i mean
follow me on twitter that's the best
place at shl i also have a government
newsletter
governor.com for slash sawhill where i
kind of write once a month about just
like
all the random stuff gumroad the fund
other things in my life
um yeah those are sort of the two the
two
best places to find me awesome man well
listen
we went almost two hours you're a legend
uh we are definitely gonna have to do
this again thank you so much for your
time yeah thanks for doing it man